I had a particular instance where I was
pulled over by a police officer and
through my younger years in life I had
obviously always followed the news and
it was stuff like Tamir rice and Michael
Brown and Eric Garner so I had already
had this preconceived notion that if I
had ever had an encounter with a police
officer it was going to go poorly and
when the moment came to fruition and I
saw the lights and the sky walks up to
my car I started freaking out and I had
never had such a visceral response I
mean just like crying shaking
remembering to like turn your camera on
put your hands on Ten and two and this
white male cop walked up which was my
worst nightmare at the time and he just
recognized something and said you know
I'm not here to hurt you at all you were
just driving a little too fast that
moment crushed something in me so I went
to the internet and I was like no
there's no way that there's good police
in America I need to look into this I
need to double down on what I believe
and I found the opposite so that's what
sparked it for me